honestly sometimes when a video has so
many dislikes i'm a little more
interested to find out like what's with
all the dislikes saying no but i know
that drives more dislikes but sometimes
that drives more views and if you're a
creator who doesn't give a [ __ ] about
the dislikes that could be very
beneficial for you
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
hey if you end up liking this video can
you go ahead and hit the dislike button
if you end up disliking this video go
ahead and hit the dislike button for one
of those supporters who ends up hitting
the like button right away which we
always appreciate not today go ahead and
hit the dislike button work together
here to make this the most disliked
video on the channel because soon you
won't even be able to see those numbers
and then it'll look like there's no
likes on this video in a couple weeks
not a single one but we'll be able to
see it on our end guys youtube has
removed the dislike counter sort of
essentially they're hiding it from you
guys the title is going to say youtube
has removed the dislike counter because
that's what everyone else is saying
algorithm you know how it goes you might
be mad being like why didn't you just
say hides it then if that's what they're
really doing well if it bothers you
go ahead and hit the dislike button
go ahead and just hit the dislike on all
of you we could say whatever we want
today
there's a lot of benefits to this
actually i love this idea immune from
your opinions now all right guys so
we're gonna keep this fairly brief we'll
go over quickly what youtube said on
their decision why to do it personally i
think that uh there's some stupidity to
what was said i don't fully believe
the reasoning for why they're saying
they're doing this and i'm gonna go into
that a little bit and we'll also talk
about if it really is as much of a big
deal something to throw your arms up in
the air about we'll talk about it let's
just go through
what frank youtube had to say we strive
to be a place where creators of all
sizes and backgrounds can find and share
their voice oh they're talking about fat
and black people uh-huh if that comment
bothered you hit the dislike button
jokes today
to ensure that youtube promotes
respectful interactions between viewers
and creators we introduce several
features and policies to improve their
experience and earlier this year we
experimented with the dislike button to
see whether or not changes could help
better protect our creators our issue
the celestials from harassment and
reduce dislike attacks where people work
to drive the number of dislikes on a
creator's videos
okay i get what they're getting at here
but i honestly believe this is rare i
don't think this is a majority of people
like whenever we upload there's usually
someone or a few who hit the dislike
button so what happens man the higher
the amount of you climb the more arrows
around your back and you're talking
about thumb down
sticking out of your back
i think what they're referring to is
like situations such as like when brie
larson launched a youtube channel
and then everyone who hates the words
virtue signaling culture
this video is going
to bring you
light the fires
and then once in a while someone might
do a video that you might not like what
they did and then you kind of harassed
them for a while and then yes i do
believe that there are those videos that
come out where they start seeing those
dislikes like what's all the dislikes
then you kind of watch the video to go
what what's your dislike yeah dislike or
you just kind of have fun with hitting
the dislike button and have a go there
just like this video today hit the
dislike button yes i see that i don't
fully believe this is the reason though
going on as part of this experiment
viewers can still see and use the
dislike button so you guys can still use
it you just don't know how many people
agree with you you just have to go to
those pleasant comment boxes but because
the count was not visible to them we
found that they were less likely to
target a video's dislike button to drive
up the count this is a fascinating part
to me because i don't think you need to
do a test to see if that would be the
case like if you can't see the count
it's like automatically my mind would go
that's an easy assumption to make
right i feel like if we hit a button but
that doesn't show anything if you don't
know how many people agree with you you
don't know if there's strength in your
numbers at all so you know you might
think twice it would be the same thing
with the like button people sometimes do
that they make their likes and dislikes
private and i'm never inclined to hit
the like or just like button at that
point because i'm like what's the point
can't see it like even now my end i
don't do it in short our experiment data
showed a reduction in dislike attacking
behavior yes that makes sense we also
heard directly from smaller creators and
those just getting started that they are
unfairly targeted by this behavior and
our experiment confirmed that this does
occur at a higher proportion
on smaller channels i
guess maybe all right we're not running
tests at the same time though i'm like
this is youtube a big part of what makes
youtube awesome
is the voting aspect to it like you yes
the like and dislike and being able to
see i feel like it's a little bit unfair
that you can see the likes but you can't
see the dislikes on it and i think the
dislikes can be beneficial for certain
videos we did a light year trailer
reaction
we had such a great time we're huge toy
story fans we're really looking forward
to that movie and then we saw these
dislikes come in 2.5
dislikes shane failure of a video and we
were like what's going on here why are
we getting all these dislikes and going
through the comments we realized that
there's a bunch of just what's the word
for it a bunch of like
dumbasses uh yeah that's one word for
stupid
idiots who can't pick up on sarcasm i
think that's the legal definition for it
just dumbasses
go look in the dictionary and then
downvote it what i wasn't aware of is
that some people a won't hear when you
say that you've actually seen toy story
and and also though some people don't
realize like what comedy is anymore or
sarcasm is even for that matter yeah i
was not made privy to the fact that we
live in a world where the lines of
comedy
and a sincere thought are blurred oh no
we live in a society what are we gonna
do no no no if you clicked off then let
me clarify yeah you're a dumbass
no it's that sometimes we are sarcasm is
extremely dry to the point that people
can't tell we're being sarcastic i hear
it all the time in real life but point
being is that was an indicator to us
it's like every once in a while we'll
make a joke i know it's gonna upset
people and i'm like ah screw it let them
get upset or we might cover a topic that
i we know is gonna get a bunch of
dislikes just from talking about it that
we're like just don't beat that person
you know for tour by that but then every
once in a while you know you can learn
something from it and also like i'm
talking from creators and on just what
we do ourselves it's helped up our
communication game when i'm like damn
this is getting dislikes because we
miscommunicated something so it's
actually helped improve our game so it's
good that we can still see it but in
terms of an audience member like for
trailer reaction honestly sometimes when
a video has so many dislikes i'm a
little more interested to find out like
what's with all the dislikes
i know that drives more dislikes but
sometimes that drives more views and if
you're a creator who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about dislikes that can be very
beneficial for you some people just
don't give a [ __ ] about that because
it's engagement and you still get the ad
revenue off of it or whatever we're not
those kind of people despite what i said
at the beginning of the video go ahead
hit the dislike button on this one
generally i'm like what do we do wrong
97 or lower it's like people hate this
video what's wrong and another reason
why i don't agree with this whole
sentiment that they're talking about of
like protecting the creators is because
the creators can still see the dislikes
everyone i've ever talked to who does
youtube who has heard me at one point
say what's all the dislikes on this
video john has heard me say a bunch and
he's like well it's only like two
percent it's usually points
2 000 people like this and 10 people
didn't and sometimes it's like 4 000
likes did and a hundred didn't like it
what did we do wrong like my mind can
sometimes go there and that's bound to
happen you know can it protect them from
the rare case where people will dislike
bomb just because other people are
disliking sure but generally i think a
lot of people who do youtube are very
much bothered by getting dislikes i've
talked with a lot of youtubers and a lot
of times they have the same thought
process i do where you get a bunch of
views and a bunch of likes but for some
reason you see the count of like 200
dislikes on a video that has 300 000
views and you're like what did i do
wrong who are these 200 people that are
mad at me you know your emotion gets in
the way of the logic and the actual math
and it takes some working through for a
certain amount of people to not be
phased by that point being is that i
don't really think they're doing to
protect people i think they're doing
this to protect like major corporations
and [ __ ]
that's where my big question comes in is
they like to throw a lot out there as
we're doing this to protect the
community and the smaller creators and
really i want to know what the yeah
corporate interests in this are because
there are a lot of big trailers and big
corporate videos i feel especially are
prone to being down vote bond and i mean
they're going to be corporations but i
wonder how much of that business that
they bring in is motivating this
i think that's the main thing that's
motivating this as we've seen over the
years
youtube has often tended a lot more to
like course it's upset like a lot of the
og
youtubers where they have been the ones
who have really talked expressively
about how so much of youtube has gone so
much more corporate and it keeps kind of
going in that direction
and
when you hear about like you know
studios or gaming movie studios gaming
studios just company products corporate
or political wise too i think dislikes
can actually help you in certain areas
on that with misinformation sometimes a
lot of how-to tutorial videos especially
i can if it got a lot of dislikes i'm
immediately like i'm not watching this
video on how to help improve my final
cut edit like
[ __ ] like that you know you're like it's
probably didn't work for a lot of people
that's why they're just liking it you
know yeah so it can help in that regard
but i i do think it's probably more to
do with the fact that you know those
companies out there corporations and
they see the dislikes and that sways
away their customers for the sales
publicity it's like when last of us two
you know people were really looking
forward to that then they heard some
leaks and they just dislike bob but
before people even got gave it a chance
like that's one example of a gaming
studio countless movie trailers movie
trailers movie trailers that don't
properly convey their source material or
whatever you're gonna get bombed
significantly yeah so and but the thing
is i don't think this is fair i think
this is kind of manipulative especially
if you're going to leave the light
counter up too might as well remove both
and only read the toxic comments which
is usually the minority of people
that's where he can easily get psyched
down you could have a you could have
thousands of likes and a few hundred
dislikes and those few hundred people
are probably commenting a negative
comment or at least half of them are so
then it takes up a lot of the comments
and then it makes you think that
everyone hates your video yeah which do
you want do you want the binary with no
context to stress over or do you want
people's very specific thoughts just
dress sophie yeah yeah
this won't really protect me in the
sense of like if i wake up in the like
okay the public can't see that i have a
you know 30 dislikes on this video but i
can see it and i'm still going to have
the same feeling i've always had
which is the hell would you guess
i've seen toy story
i know all the toy stories that's where
my mom's going for years
i've seen toy story uh yeah guys what do
you think about this does it really
matter to you is it a big deal everyone
seems to be making a big deal comment
below a positive thought and hit the
dislike button
you